bonjour les fans de star wars merci pour tout
votre soutien incroyable et votre réponse à
obi-wan kenobi
j'ai des nouvelles importantes notre première
date se déplace dans quelques jours
du mercredi au vendredi 27 mai
mais voici la partie passionnante les
deux premiers épisodes seront  première ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors assurez-vous d'écouter les deux
épisodes d'obi-wan kenobi en streaming le
vendredi 27 mai exclusivement sur
disney plus
[Musique]
le combat est terminé,
nous avons perdu
[Musique]
restez cachés
[Musique  ]
la clé
pour chasser les jedi
cette patience
jedi ne peut pas aider ce qu'ils sont
leur compassion
laisse une trace
le code jedi est comme une démangeaison
il ne peut pas s'en empêcher
où est-il
[Musique]
toi